what happened during the pandemic and
how did you guys deal with that it was
spicy it was super spicy uh should I
tell you thre It Blow by blow yeah I
would love it story it was pretty Punchy
so we went so we had um February half
term famously really big for us it's
kind of the first like thoring of winter
it says 2020 2020 February halterm uh
like you know pizza and families is Big
so it's obviously always a big week for
us had biggest week the company ever had
in February after
and how many how many stores do you have
at that point um it's a great question I
reckon about 17 W okay something like
that so yeah 20 February 2020 and then
our rmd who is a total Legend but is
definitely on the kind of like
germaphobe scale he's like oh you know
this thing is getting quite big like do
you think this is this is going to be a
thing and I was like this is so not
going to be a thing every time it comes
around there some kind of bird flu it
goes away again it's nonsense obviously
we then had this like weird early
warning system where a lot of people who
work for us are Italian and we started
to get calls up from Italians being like
my moms told me that I can't come to
work like uh obviously we'd seen on the
news and it was getting big and like
okay so this is getting closer and
closer to home but we were getting like
the real like on your doorstep human
reaction of like I'm I'm not I'm not
happy coming to work I don't know what
this is I don't know so this was growing
and
growing uh and obviously you know we
were increasingly like aware of it I
went I remember I went went around on a
Sunday I went to every piz of re and
just s chat to the team is like how do
you feel about this you know anyone who
doesn't want to work doesn't have to
work um but obviously we're not going to
be able to pay you if you choose not to
work totally respect the decision
there'll be a job there for you if you
want but you know we've got to keep
going then we had this like absolute
nuclear moment where Boris came out and
was like and this is probably early
first week of March yeah he basically
announced on the news that like people
shouldn't go to bars restaurants or
clubs yep they shouldn't do it but
didn't close us down give us any kind of
like you know support y so suddenly our
Revenue which is we were definitely
seeing flag we were definitely star to
see Revenue come down quite aggressively
by 7th 8th of March yep then Boris comes
out and was like don't go to these
places and it went like through the roof
like absolute collapse and so we were
there still open still trading but with
no one coming yeah and it was like like
literally no one I mean like I think I
think our Revenue probably dropped by
like 60 to 70%
overnight uh so like I mean we open in
trading but we knew that every single
day we were losing money yeah like you
know there's just no way that's going to
work so uh you know restaurants famously
thin margins anyway so you know losing
losing 10 20% is enough to cause you
anyway so that happened um we were like
what the hell do we do now and basically
we had to we had to make a decision and
we
decided we did two things one we sat
down and modeled out uh what we called
the apocalypse scenario oh nice which
showed six weeks of closure which was
like obviously nowhere near what we
ended up having uh and we never forget
we did it we did the spreadsheet was the
four of us senior bods in the room did
the spreadsheet pressed enter and it was
like oh actually six weeks of closure
that's all right we can survive this
this is pretty good and then I after do
is like oh forgot to link cell a to
cellb Boom like business is gone in six
weeks like nothing left so so why is it
is it because you have to pay the rent
for the stores and you've got to pay the
staff or like yeah so we we were
modeling it like with everyone still
being paid like you know no this is
obviously before like any so any we
didn't know anything about fur had come
around then so we had this week of like
right we know that we phys the business
will implode yes so what do we do now
we've got all these stores they're
losing money that's Proby scary how how
feel when you saw the spreadsheet it was
totally horrendous and I genuinely
genuinely did go to the human element of
like what are we going to do we can't
fire all these people like what are they
going to do so we basically took the
decision that our plan was obviously you
know everyone was nervous of it and it
was like do we but you know we were
getting a lot like why are you opening
like you shouldn't be opening it's not
safe blah blah blah we were like no the
best thing we can do for the most people
in this business is to trade our asses
off as much as we can keep the pizzeria
open as much as we can push out Left
Right Center tell the world that we're
open and trading and if you want to come
and have a pizza we're here for you and
basically give as many people as many
hours to work as we can and hope that
this all blows over basically um and we
did that and we got definitely a lot of
push back we got a lot of people telling
us that we were responsible and blah
blah blah but we were like I think this
is the best thing we can do for everyone
anyway about a week after that we got
the sort of your pizzer now needs to
close everything needs to close and he
shut by the end of today um but in that
same I think that was the day the day
they told us we had to close and it was
like you need to by 11:00 at night have
closed everything up and gone and you
can do delivery but nothing else um they
also announced fur and we were sat in
this meeting I don't forget all of us on
Zoom watching rishy reading out with f
and there was speculation of like is it
going to be 40% of salary covered is it
going to be 60 yeah I think Denmark had
done 60 so we were like seems un likely
be more than that and then uh came out
and said we're going to cover 80% of
everyone's salary and I literally
remember like we were all just in tears
we were all quite drunk drinking like
everyone was drinking whatever their
respect of drink was in their house
watching this happen just being like
this is unbelievable like all these
people are going to get 80% of their
salary so the government was covering
80% of people salaries so we we went
from I think at point we probably had
250 people yeah we went to 250 people
working for piz pilgrams to 248 people
on Furlow wow uh and who were getting 8%
of their salary which means that you
just pay 20% or no their salary go they
unfortunately got 80% couldn't afford to
pay the 20 but we took the decision at
that point because we' had so much like
I'm scared to come to work I don't want
to be we were like we're not going to do
deliver we're just going to shut yeah
and we're going to everyone's going to
get 80% of their salary they're going to
be at home obviously I would wish it was
100% but it's not we subsequently topped
up quite a few people to 100% but it's
difficult in an hour's business because
obviously we did a lot of like what
normal looks like but anyway we didn't
have to let anyone go which is
unbelievable uh everyone you know
everyone stayed in the company we closed
all of our pizza rear and we just we
just like sat there being like okay so
this is weird we're going to survive
which was amazing because at the point
you know there was one point was like
well we'll be out of business by April
yeah um so we would sat there and then
we started getting after about two weeks
of that just going like what the
just happened we started getting calls
from managers being like you know what
I'm really really bored and actually you
know if you're thinking of reopening a
pizzer do delivery only Count Me In type
thing nice that started to happen and me
and James like chomping at the bit to
get a pizzia back open because we were
like Jesus we had all these pizzer reers
you know all those pizza rovens burning
and now they're all off um anyway so we
decided after we had enough of those
calls from enough people we were like
let's open one so we we reopened
Victoria which had been our most recent
opening um we had no we were in what you
call a rentree period so when you first
take on a lease you tend to agree a
period of time with a landlord where you
don't pay any rent which helps to cover
some of your capital expenditure and I
think we were in a sort of a year-long
rentree period on that store so it's
like well open there there's no kind of
awkward conversations with the landlords
then about what the rent is because
we're not paying rent anyway so it's
irrelevant so we can just open it
there's no kind of politics there it's a
good location and we'll do deliver rout
so that was the plan uh we started
gearing up for that to happen we're all
very excited to have one open again and
then um my brother being my brother just
called me one day and was like I've had
this idea to
send to to basically put the ingredients
for a pizza into a box and send it
through the post to someone and then
they could make a pizza at home while
they're stuck at home and I was like but
what do you mean he's like well what I'm
going to do is I'm going to send you one
so he basically like put two doughballs
tomato sauce mozzarella parmesan flour
oil basil in literally into a pizza box
and little plastic tubs and then wrapped
it in Wool there's this proper company
called wool cool so you put it I mean
it's all pretty normal now really but
like wrapped it in Wool with an ice pack
posted it to me got it the next day
through the post uh opened it up it like
exploded everywhere just but it was cold
probed the probe the dough and it was
like safe to save you know Refrigeration
temperature it's like this this could be
a thing so we were just looking I think
for something to do on Instagram that
was a bit more interesting than
deliveroo yeah so like why we make these
kits and um this is before any
restaurant meal kits existed this is
like no one was doing it it was the
first one I'd ever seen and when we make
these kits we'll put them up for sale uh
we'll make 50 we'll put them up for sale
on Instagram when we first on the day we
open Victoria we'll make them available
and then we'll make them in Victoria
with the team that are there and we can
just post them to people and you know
it's just a fun thing for Instagram put
50 up for sale on that Wednesday having
promoted it I think on the Monday and we
sold the first 50 in like under a minute
having planed sell them in a week and we
were like okay this is a thing so then
we did another 50 the next day sold them
in 20 seconds and I was starting to get
my head around Shopify and I could see
that like 200 people tried to put them
in the basket in the sort of 30 seconds
that they were available and I was like
this is really interesting so on the
third day we had this like sliding doors
moment of do we do we try and scale this
sort of do obviously there's a thing
here do we try and slowly grow it build
our you know ability to make them and
like slowly expand or do we just try and
sell as Mel as we can and well so we
were like look let's just put 1100 for
sale we basically put 1100 of these kits
for sale saying like you will get them
at some point before the 1 of May yeah
bearing in mind this was the 1 of April
uh and we're like I think you know we'll
just do that see what happens and we
sold all 1100 kits in 40 minutes wow and
it was like I think still the most
profitable hour in the history of each
pilgrims and suddenly we had this thing
where it was like holy crap this is a
thing and we were on like Sunday brunch
and we were growing this thing we you
know we had we then opened another
Pizzeria to try and meet the demand we
kept buying like chest freezers a bit
like that yeah and then we'd like get
all these ice packs and we'd fill them
like fill these chest freezers with ice
packs and be like cool so what 12 hours
later you go back you come back they're
all Frozen they weren't so that just
everything was just chaos restaurants
and production facilities are like as
far apart from each other as possible
but by February 21 we were doing 10,000
units a week of this of this of this at
home that's not bad I mean it was we
were turning over more than we were in
the restaurants before Co it was mental
oh yeah that's cool so literally like
this stupid idea just grew and grew and
it meant that we had cash flow the whole
way through we every everyone from like
the Spice Girls to stormy to all these
people made these kits it's huge on
Instagram we grew our Instagram
following by like
50,000 um it was mad and uh it save the
company remember we had cash flow the
whole way through um we were able to get
a whole load of people off fur to help
us make the kits and they obviously got
their 100% payback and yeah and we just
we kind of feathered it in with and then
you know we were reopening Pizza rear
and and we still do pizza in the post
today as it was named but um it's
obviously like so much smaller than it
was yeah but we have about we have about
350 400 subscribers who get it either
once a week or subscription box type
think it now is a subscription and C
Revenue it yeah exactly and you know it
was just it was I mean it meant that we
never ever sat still in Co it actually
like made you know certainly for the
parts of the world where we don't have a
pizzeria you know people in Edinburgh
have now heard of us where they wouldn't
have done before yeah and uh yeah it was
an amazing it was an amazing solution to
the problem basically hey friends thank
you so much for watching if you enjoyed
this clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day bye-bye